who's been shot out of a cannon and gone
up into the stratosphere more than tom
from when he was very young he became a
big movie star risky business right he
was a kid right he wasn't born you know
on a soundstage in Hollywood you know
he's fella it was a kid he was an
ordinary kid from New Jersey or whatever
and he becomes this phenomenon and it
just keeps going it doesn't stop it just
keeps going and going and going now he's
been making he's been one of the biggest
movie stars in the world for 25 years
and that's a lot yeah and I say to
myself maybe there's a religion or maybe
there's a philosophy that helped him to
negotiate that space because you're
getting the bends man you're like who do
I trust what's real and I say to myself
I don't care what you do whatever you
need to do whatever pill you need to
take whatever diet you need to go on
whatever type of pillow you need to
sleep on who gives a [ __ ] it's none of
your business your business right it's
like--go is if you're not hurting
anybody and I don't know that they're
hurt Minnie I don't know that right
people say things and I go okay that's
cool I understand that there's some
extreme situations there but I say to
myself I go to work with Tom we have a
ball yeah and it's like the it's like
the height it's like the height of
moviemaking you have a great time and I
really don't care